london soho die partymeile im herzen der
stadt
vereinzelt erinnern masken an die
pandemie doch das motto der nacht man
lebt nur einmal
großartig wieder ausgeben zu können bis
sinnvoll und keiner trägt maske aber
ansonsten super der alkoholpegel steigt
das abstandsgebot feld ist doch sicher
solange du nur mit deinen leuten ab
hengst probleme gibt es wenn jemand wie
er zu nahe kommt der gehört nicht zu uns
sie wollen wir endlos scheinende monate
vergessen machen
wir waren so viele abende zu hause super
party für zwei nichts wie raus wir gehen
uns sonst so auf die nerven
endlich abwechslung noah olic l und
daniel haben sich seit herbst nicht
sehen können essen quatschen ein paar
drinks gar nicht so einfach einen platz
zu finden
dabei hat die stadt halb so hoch zur
fußgängerzone erklärt die idee so viele
tische mit genügend abstand die möglich
im freien nur da ist feiern sind treffen
erlaubt
das geht zu weit 0 abstand oder
ähnliches erst wenn alle geringste ist
es sinnvoll die beschränkungen
aufzuheben
nein hier ist doch kaum einer kämpft so
viele menschen um dich herum das kann
nicht sicher sein
hier sind leute die korona haben und die
das gar nicht wissen das macht mir
wirklich angst 15 minuten durchzwängen
später ein freies plätzchen mit der
korona app anmelden kontakt
nachverfolgung ermöglichen was die dame
am nachbartisch für einen bezahlt es
fühlt sich an als ob wir auf dem weg in
lockdown nummer vier
die leute führen sich auf wie wilde und
dazu sind das doch keine zwei meter
tisch abstand nach vier monaten strengen
lockdown sind die infektionszahlen
niedrig treffen im freien seien da
weniger problematisch so neueste
studienergebnisse corona ansteckung ein
innenraum problem aber ohne risiko sei
es nicht wenn die bevölkerung noch nicht
vollständig geimpft ist wenn man zu
schnell öffnet ist das in verbindung mit
den virus varianten mittel und
langfristig die größte gefahr wenn man
erst halb durch ist mit dem im programm
riskiert man dass das virus auf
ungeimpfte ausweicht die infektion hin
zu nehmen so wie gerade in chile nach
dem 40 prozent geimpft waren hat man
sehr schnell geöffnet nun gilt wieder
ein lock down und in den krankenhäusern
hatten sehr viele jüngere es gibt kein
handbuch fürs öffnen in einer pandemie
einen vorsichtigen weg geht könig
fußball
beim ligapokal finale mancity gegen
tottenham im londoner wembley-stadion
8000 handverlesene fans erlaubt drei
tests sind pflicht zwei davor einer
danach
teil eines experiments fußball mit fans
geht das schon wieder
es hat nerven gekostet weil du nach dem
letzten test auf das ergebnis per sms
war ist und du musst ihnen im zeitraum
gestern bis 13 uhr heute ist er positiv
ist ein geld futsch und wir wollen so
sehr ins stadion
es fühlt sich so viel sicherer an als
jeden tag mit dem bus zur uni mit leuten
von denen ich nicht weiß wo sie waren
was sie gemacht haben
hier hält sich jeder an die
abstandsregeln alle sind getestet und
respektvoll einfach nur ein echt super
tag bleiben die besucher gesund geht
alles gut könnten zum em-finale im
sommer 45.000 ins stadion halb voll
unter zwei bedingungen das impfprogramm
läuft weiter ohne probleme und es taucht
keine variante auf die alles
durcheinanderbringt dabei jüngst unter
verdacht dass sie die impfstoffe
austricksen könnte die indische variante
seit freitag ist die einreise aus indien
untersagt rückreisende mit britischem
wohnsitz müssen auf eigene kosten im
hotel quarantäne außerhalb indiens ist
die variante in großbritannien am
häufigsten wir haben zwar erste rund 200
fälle entdeckt es fehlt an genügend
daten aber die
ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit mit welcher
wucht ist indien trifft dass es in
pakistan und bangladesch auftaucht ist
wirklich besorgniserregend vor allem da
man annimmt dass bis zu 80 prozent der
inder schon immunität haben schon mal
erkrankt waren entweder ist die variante
sehr viel ansteckender oder sie kann
menschen die korona hatten mühelos
nochmal infizieren
für die indische gemeinde in london sind
die nachrichten aus der alten heimat ein
albtraum während um sie herum das leben
erwacht geschäfte wieder öffnen fürchte
trencin lack war um ihre tochter sonal
trotz ständiger videoanrufe erzählt sie
fresse sie die angst auf ich werde
verrückt rufe ständig an ermahne sie das
haus nicht zu verlassen
das nicht zu tun dies nicht klar
vielleicht halten sie sich daran aber
ich habe noch mehr familie dort rennens
tochter wohnt mit ihrem mann und zwei
kindern nach
wir tun alles um uns selbst zu schützen
dass es uns nicht erwischt es fühlt sich
einsam an ich vermisse meine familie so
sehr
niemand verlässt bei familie georgia in
wembley das haus wenn sie mit indien
sprechen wann sie kommen können fragt
amys vater über den bildschirm
der vater wurde positiv getestet die
großmutter ist dann corona gestorben bei
der beerdigung dabei sein unterstützen
nichts geht
wir fühlen uns so hilflos gerade wir
können nicht hinreisen und uns kümmern
dafür sorgen dass sie anständig
medizinisch versorgt werden
wie alle wollen wir nur dass wir bei der
familie sein können
trauer und freudentänze liegen dicht
beieinander in diesen tagen auch wenn im
wenige kilometer entfernt ist sowohl die
sorge mit feiert doch am ende gilt man
ist nur einmal jung zu schmerzhaft
bedrohlich der karte auf werden könnte
die show muss weitergehen